um well last year you got an emmy for
doing vice president harris on snl so
when you do this do you ever hear from
the people that you're imitating
when when the election was happening um
i got to be a part of a fundraiser with
kamala harris and hillary clinton
um with my good friend amy poehler and
that was like uh
yeah you know moment um
you know i i've loved the political
characters over the years on saturday
life but i've never had the chance to
really be a part of the election in that
way and it was really incredible
especially
this past election and everything
leading up to it it almost was very
cathartic to be
involved in something because a lot of
the days that i was experiencing felt
very
tough or helpless or strange and
felt like i was doing something
and i was i just feel really proud to
have been able to um
gotten a chance to play her i think
she's amazing
and um just so cool and so wonderful and
i'm so
i'm so happy i feel so lucky that we've
got her for these four years um yeah
and it's not very dramatic so there's
not much for me to do at the moment
we'll see yeah
i love it
[Music]